sure random all right let's see what
we're going to be hit with what set up
let's do it team black ah ok bishops
these guys don't have to move in order
to contribute unprotected ponds they're
all protected where do I want to Castle
if I'm to Castle I have to clear out
Bishop Knight rook night to Castle a
queen side I need to move my queen and
night out but if I castle a clean side
you'll note that this these bishops are
like firing right down at me so I don't
know what I want to do maybe I want to
play the copycat game i think i might
want to do this also mmm my night and I
don't like obstructing that pond just
yeah how do i get my queen out I don't
ya how do about how do we both get our
queen out it's going to be a problem let
me do let me do the same fight for some
control over one of the central squares
pretty much on the first move of Fisher
randoms I'm looking at the c d e and f
ponds and which one to move two squares
forward any one of those four will
contribute to some control either the
control of or the code the you know
would occupy the center and control but
ok I think I still want to do what my
opponent is doing so now at least both
bishops can see where the Knights belong
okay i don't think i could allow this
Bishop to play to e5 and slam the door
on this guy in the corner so a
structural change what do I do with my
night I just don't know i think i have
to play here let's let's do it i get
developed and it's tough i don't want to
do this because i'm blocking in my epon
and i don't want to do this move either
i mean i would want to do this to get my
night here but that just seems so
weakening to my light squares maybe it's
okay
hang on how did my queen get working
she's so stupid actually my opponents
having the same problems the Queen the
queen is the difficult piece to get
working if I go here my night kind of
looks like a giant giant clown right you
go here and he's having problems big
problems I had a problem on the clock
already what do I do d 697 and then try
and get in this advance I guess mmm or
maybe this pawn push and then night here
then he looks stupid I guess one of them
has to look stupid and maybe it'll be
him okay let me try this we try this
actually yeah that's a brilliant idea
because I'm not even threatening this
pawn advance because of pins because of
an unprotected guy on E 8 ok he looks he
is he is suffering right now from tahoe
pond syndrome right here tall pine
syndrome going on for this guy wow wow
what do you even do let's do this now at
least I could do this and then get my
knight to e7 and then maybe I could play
my pond up to like Gigi no this is B
this is the B file now I could do this
now I could do this and then I can jump
my knight in here so I'm finally
starting to see some coordination and
out i never really consider taking this
night all right let's go this night my
opponent i think has better coordination
tonight's going to be a tough guy once
he gets here okay i think i want to get
my queen working be 5 be 4
Knight f3 to e5 seems interesting my
opponent can out Castle seems a bit
crazy but I'm going to do it for a
second I thought b5 can be met with be
four but that's not the case unless my
opponent wants to drop this guy on c3
and then everything else so this is a
this is now a whole as a result of this
last pond advanced c5 is their way my
opponent can be making use of that they
might be able two nite be 32 c 5 stuff
but ok alright I insist I want to really
still try to get this advanced in I
could Castle kingside this night if it
eventually comes here okay maybe I
should just castle right now yeah I
better castle as well so we're both
castled and do I want to first move my
queen up a step before I play be four or
die just play be four right away cb4
takes takes rook takes Queen takes am i
okay with my queen then being on a eight
instead of be eight because I might one
side push here I might want to play my
queen up to be five it seems like just a
more active square but you know what
maybe I want to catch with my night come
to think of it let me let me do this
normally I would want to just recapture
like that but you know what I'm gonna go
with my night and the reason for this is
so that it makes life a bit more
uncomfortable for the Queen you'll note
by putting pressure on see to it says
you know what you better not call so far
away you have to babysit upon and the
night you'll know it can't be kicked
away so easily canny right if ever see
three well then this is an issue so
what's this pond doing
something now he's doing something and
now maybe I could get my queen in 2d six
and I'm completely I'm coordinated
pretty well my rooks and direct contact
of one another right here seems like the
right thing to do there was pressure on
c5 against III not so easy maybe I
should have considered Queen here
however c4 might have been a problem
yeah probably probably would have been a
problem okay so what's the story with
this guy oh man 140 about even a time
let's see like guards here maybe I want
to get my rook off the same diagonal as
that I let me let me do this now let me
let me I don't know what I want to do oh
I want to go here I think there might be
some night here I want to be in a spot
to be able to take and still have
coverage on this square there could
still be some tricky tactics with an
eventual fork night here take stakes oh
my night has to run away the queen is
defending that now I missed that okay so
i still have coverage for this point
could it be attacked again nights on the
same diagonal as one another with two
squares separating them are fighting for
the same squares so c5 and b6 are
controlled for as long as I have this
guy here it's kind of canceling out the
one on a4 so I'm looking elsewhere
looking at g5 the night playing here I
think my rook wants to play here to
watch over this okay so the night is
going to be playing here I don't know
that I want to take here or just don't
know yeah i'm going to take open up this
file pieces are going to be landing here
though what it would it what a foolish
foolish foolish piece right here in f7
less than a minute okay we're going to
have mass exchanges and after the smoke
clears I just don't know
I just don't know yeah I just don't know
let's try that 47 seconds where this is
going to be a rat race if you didn't
realize that's what is going to come
down to who can move the mouse fast
let's go here pressure on this palm pre
move that 52 seconds 50 seconds fourteen
white man that we were we were both hit
what a very difficult arrangement my
opponent made better use of the position
go here I guess I'm my bishop he's
definitely really really bad but he's
serving a I guess a decent role in
having to watch over a pond that's quite
weak and I just want I want to trade
Queens actually let's make that happen
look at the Queen's off the Queen's are
off and now I want to target this pun I
actually want my king up here oh they're
dropping that pond what's the trick
other down on time I got a pig here pig
alert everything's falling now 20
seconds I could just take that he's
passed and he's fast I should have given
a check forced the king in that the
other direction so now I'm threatening
this okay that's winning now it's
winning the farm pac-man mode I do have
a flight square let's go I was I not
going fast there she just grabbed this
guy defend everything everything's
defended keep pushing just get behind it
watch out for stalemate no stalemates no
time my opponent was better further
ninety-five percent of the game I think
good game let me back up
um I don't know what else to do here it
seems like this is the best plan to go
forward with if I don't do if I don't
react properly right away in these
fisher randoms i could turn out one of
the bishops just gets killed in case in
point right here like I have to i'm
pretty sure i have to take if I just I
don't know if I just move my knight here
my opponent plays d for i try to
undermine it and why it says so up
playing e5 if that structure is allowed
d4 when I have the coordinates run 'if
I've and f4 if that is structures
allowed I'm dead so I'm already
concerned about that for move one so
that's why I was thinking it had to do
that I like this pawn break in the
center for white I would have liked to
get that in if I was playing the white
side but okay I really couldn't get that
in could I and what could white do even
better to put pressure on me I like the
night move okay he doesn't have it
didn't really have a better square this
is fine castle yeah you know my my
opponents just outputting me here
everything is just really harmonious
here there's got to be some better plan
let's see what would I do is white here
how do you how do you do better here
because after the smoke clears it's a
better structure for white and white has
a better bishop everything is pointing
at this guy being bad news so what do
you do here how about then while this
night is actually a bit stranded isn't
he this turned out to be a slight
problem I think white would just how
would much rather like to have direct
sight of a five so how can you make that
work to be honest this was my first
thought to just take the bishop and then
plant the Queen up in this nice strong
post on d4 and it would come with tempo
and then maybe even look to trade Queens
Queen B 6 as a follow-up Bishop takes
Knight takes Queen D for hitting the
night I don't think I want to play here
and work myself into a pin
as a follow up queen bee six maybe do
that get the Queen's off just so this
rook could finally get active and then
try and target this pond this is
something to maybe be considering Bishop
h3 once you get to this point my
opponents clearly better here clearly
better but time was an issue if anything
Bishop h3 and this pond is going to drop
there is some concern however still in
this end game because I could be putting
pressure on the beep on or if the beep
on moves the sepan etc so i don't know
how advantageous this position is to get
into the endgame if you're not cracking
through at e 6 then maybe these rooks
aren't looking so bright but we were
having a mouse race at this point where
we okay a good game good good game let
me call those out of this and let me see
where we are at with the tournament less
than 10 less than 9 minutes and there
are 91 players okay eight minutes 15
seconds alrighty let me go to a game
that's going on right now I'm done with
playing for right now and actually let
me take like a quick two minute break
and I will be right back
um try to see something here real quick
I've noticed